[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sell it
welt heute gibt's eine new york
cheesecake und zwar ist das ein richtig
guter käsekuchen
zugegeben ich war noch nie in new york
und habe ihn auch noch nie dort gegessen
aber ich weiß dass der new york
cheesecake auch bei uns hier in
deutschland sehr verbreitet ist deswegen
habe ich hier heute das rezept für euch
typischerweise hat man unten einen keks
boden damit butter vermischt wird der
wird dann mit gebacken
die creme schiff wird mit dem frischkäse
gemacht und dadurch ist sie eben auch so
ultra cremig ich muss zugeben
kalorienarm ist er nicht gerade aber er
ist wirklich sehr lecker
bei mir gibt's heute ein etwa kurier
dazu also so eine richtig tolle erdbeer
soße die passt vor allem geschmacklich
sehr gut dazu farblich sehr gut dazu und
da gerade erdbeersaison ist solltet ihr
die abwehr zeit auf jeden fall ausnutzen
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal gleich
wie ich den boden hersteller und der
creme und deswegen ziehe ich da vorne
mal die zutaten an zutaten brauche ich
250 km/h kekse 100 gramm butter 750
gramm frischkäse im doppel nach stufe
200 gramm schwamm 200 gramm zucker
eine unbehandelte zitrone etwas vanille
extrakt feier und zwei eigelb so erst
einmal nämlich jetzt die harfe kekse
die werde ich in dem mixa einfach ein
bisschen verkleinern fand er keinen mixa
habt steckt die kekse einfach in einen
gefrierbeutel und rollt mit dem ausland
starb drüber die butter nämlich und
wehrt sie jetzt hier im topf schmelzen
in der zwischenzeit
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die keks brösel mit mutter
und ich mag die hafa kekse total gerne
weil sie einfach ganz so trocken sind
und wirklich einen richtig tollen
geschmack haben
die kann man auch selber machen und wenn
ihr möchtet dass ich die man selber
machen könnt ihr mir einfach einen
kommentar da lassen dann mache ich die
gerne ich merke jetzt gerade wenn mir
dass meine kick sind wie sie in butter
lustig waren wahrscheinlich denn die
masse ist ein bisschen zu weich das
heißt ich gebe es hier noch mal ein paar
kekse mit dazu dies kann entweder noch
mal hardcore eingeben oder ich möchte ja
dass jetzt das fett ein bisschen
aufgesaugt wird das heißt ich gebe
einfach ein paar trockene kekse wie
löffelbiskuits zum beispiel mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt ist die masse perfekt und jetzt
auch nicht mehr so nass wie gerade eben
jetzt kommt sie deinen bakri den habe
ich bereits auf 24 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und drücke ich die masse
jetzt schön flach
[Musik]
der [ __ ] boden wird jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad ober
unterhitze für 15 minuten vor gebacken
danach muss ich ihn abkühlen lassen und
der zwischenzeit ruhig schon mal die
creme zusammen für die creme nämlich
jetzt eine küchenmaschine ihr könnt das
ganze aber auch mit einem schneebesen
mit einem schneebesen per hand berühren
ich gebe die zutaten hier rein also den
frischkäse zuerst da kommt jetzt das man
twittert so
[Musik]
und etwas zitronenschale den saft der
zitrone gebe ich jetzt ja auch mit dazu
und jetzt kommt noch etwas panel exakt
mit dazu ihr könnt jetzt ein bis zwei
teelöffel rhein geben damit das ganze
wirklich richtig toll nach vanille
schmeckt jetzt wird die masse verrührt
nicht auf höchster stufe sondern bei
niedrigster stufe
denn ich möchte nur dass der frischkäse
masse cremig wird und nicht luft
eingeschlagen wird und daher bei
niedriger stufe und lieber etwas
langsamer jetzt kombinieren nacheinander
die eier mit dass so das heißt immer
eine 1 mit rein und dann erst berühren
und dann das
[Musik]
die creme wurde ist ordentlich cremig
gerührt die werde ich jetzt abdecken
der teig backtage noch und den lasse ich
dann wie gesagt kurz abkühlen denn wenn
ich jetzt die masse auf den heißen
kuchen gibt dann wird sie natürlich
extrem flüssig das möchte ich nicht
daher lasse ich den teig abkühlen und
dann kommt die führung
jetzt kommt die cremige füllung hier auf
den abgekühlten boden
dann las ich das ganze hier nochmal
stehen für etwa fünf minuten damit
einfach ein bisschen ruhm kam der luft
entweichen kann denn wie gesagt ich
möchte keine luftige füllung sondern
eine cremige damit der kuchen bei der
gleichen temperatur 15 minuten weiter
gebacken und dann schallt stets darunter
auf 130 grad und da wird er da noch mal
45 minuten weiter gebacken
jetzt schauen wir mal nach dem
käsekuchen debug zeit ist abgelaufen ich
warte einfach mal ein bisschen wenn
jetzt noch so wie bei mir ein bisschen
zu alt wird stelle ich den backofen
jetzt einfach noch mal 15 minuten länger
danach mache ich ihn aus und lasst den
kuchen hier komplett drin abkühlen
jetzt ist der käse kuchen fertig ich
habe ihnen mit einem sauberen geschickt
abgedeckt und danach einfach kühl
gestellt das heißt nachdem er
vollständig abgekühlt war kam er dann
noch mal in den kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich den torten rand lösen
[Musik]
plötzlich den auf eine tortenplatte und
canet debug folie wegziehen
[Musik]
während der kuren abgekühlt ist habe ich
hier schon mal ein etwa prix vorbereitet
und so habe ich dafür 450 gramm
erdbeeren klein geschnitten und diese
mit 75 gramm zucker gekocht das war am 3
1 1 verliert zu fahren und ich habe da
noch eine halbe zitrone mit rein gegeben
das heißt den sach davon und das ganze
dann schön püriert das ist jetzt auch
abgekühlt und so dachte mir rat jetzt
gleich die torte probieren
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den new york cheesecake
bereits angeschnitten und mit der soße
übergossen
ich wollte eigentlich den morath warten
aber dennoch mit der sanierung auf der
baustelle sind heute nämlich muffins
gebacken und die darf sie jetzt gerade
auf der baustelle verteilen
deswegen probiere ich stehe jetzt für
euch also ihr solltet ihnen ich finde
direkt aus dem kühlschrank nicht
probieren sondern einfach ein bisschen
bei raumtemperatur stehen lassen
etwa eine halbe stunde und dann essen
einmal poor also richtig schön dass man
schön standfest und toll helge backen
also sondern genau aussehen
sehr schön cremig und da passt natürlich
dass etwa perry perfekt dazu und falls
ihr keine erdbeeren mit könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch in berlin oder blaubeeren
oder einfach alles was ihr gerade da
damit noch mal probieren
also ich finde den new york cheesecake
sehr lecker vor allem passt dieser
süß-sauer die süßsaure pyrit wirklich
perfekt mit dem süßen käsekuchen und ich
finde vor allem kommt die vanille
richtig gut durch falls ihr jetzt auch
lust darauf bekommen habt dann schaut
nochmal auf salehs - blog.de vorbei da
steht noch mal das ganze rezept und ich
wünsche euch jetzt schon mal ganz viel
spaß danach machen und bis zum nächsten
mal den schnappe ich mir jetzt dass mir
noch ein espresso aus und setze mich auf
die dafür und ließen
[Musik]